president biden's agenda and a tailspin
in hopes of a comeback dwindling
democrats like congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez are taking serious shots
at moderates joe manchin and kirsten
cinema some of the attacks are getting
pretty hairy listen
i don't believe she's really given a
compelling case as to why she should be
re-nominated as the democratic nominee
for united states senate in arizona i
she has proven herself an obstacle to
the right to vote to the united in the
united states she is not an ally on
civil rights i think she's
that's what i have to say the major
reason we don't have a build back better
bill to address all of these problems is
because cinema and mansion have played
right into the conservative talking
points
so while democrats tear themselves apart
dem strategist james carville is telling
his party quote this is not a time to
complain it's a time to act so let's
talk about real things in real language
to real people right harold i'm going to
come to you first because these are your
people um carville also said that he's
some of them he thinks
democrats are too emotional and he said
he thinks they're spending too much time
and energy on down ballot races that
they have no chance of winning what do
you think about that so i think james
has said a lot of things over the last
few weeks that i tend to agree with and
this is this is another in the string of
them uh politics is about solving
people's problems not advancing your own
personal agenda
not advancing your own personal brand of
politics now if it all if it all
collides and you're helping people and
you're doing those things that's one
thing
but it it it's a little bothersome and a
little tiring to hear a progressive or
moderate talk about the other as if
somehow another they have a monopoly on
being right
politics again is about solving people's
problems democrat or republican alike
and if democrats whoever's in the
majority don't accomplish those things
they generally get voted out
now this is not something that just goes
with democrats you see on the
republicans that liz cheney's trying to
be kick they're trying to kick her out
of the party in washington and in her
home state and even adam clensinger the
guy they're trying to kick him out as
well
and if you don't recognize these things
as a party that's in power you're going
to lose power so democrats
if this is what we want
the power but to to all this internet's
in fighting here in the middle of a time
in which we our president is in the low
or low 40s or high 30s then we deserve
to be defeated in november if we're
serious about having a majority then
behave like it
past things that are going to solve
people's problems from the border to
crime to inflation
past things that people want to see you
work on if you pass things that people
don't want to see you work on then
you're likely going to lose the majority
and that's the path we find ourselves on
i hope the president can rescue that
from rescue us from that and i hope that
democrats in the house and the senate
progressives and moderates alike learn
how to work together i think the key in
what you just said is pass something
pass something right so judge the
president spent an inordinate amount of
time and energy on bill back better it
is now stalled out um so much like
carville says democrats are spending a
lot of time on races they're not going
to win they're also doubling down on
issues they know they're not going to
win voting rights right how many times
did senator manchin say he was not going
to overturn the filibuster like 17 times
a day yet they still went down this path
well you know joe biden came in saying
that he was going to be the great uniter
and that his years in the senate would
give him the ability to you know cross
the aisle and get legislation passed and
then they realize at the end of the
first year he's no good at getting any
legislation passed but what i think is
really fascinating to me in this whole
thing with the democrats and and i agree
with harold to a certain extent yeah
there are some reports writing that down
judgment yeah no that that that were
that certain republicans like you know
liz cheney or adam kunzinger you know
they're not quite in the mainstream but
i've never heard people call the names
uh that they're calling the democrats
are calling each other and you know for
aoc to come out with those names and all
the other democrats you know to follow
cinema into a bathroom i mean these are
tactics like i'm waiting for democrats
to cancel each other out because that's
where they are they're ready to cancel
each other out get big tech to cancel
out cinema and mansion because they're
so angry and the progressives actually
say the reason that joe biden isn't
doing well it's not because of us
progressives it's because he isn't a
progressive enough if he'd move more
left he'd have the whole party behind
him i mean everybody's a little wacky in
this greg what is hotter right now the
democratic civil war between the
progressives and the moderates or the
republican civil war between the pro and
anti-trump people
i would say i'm the hotter of both
uh why can't politics be like sports
and have team trades what if the
republicans traded lynn cheney and adam
kinzinger for cinema and mansion what a
perfect trade that would be right what
we're okay we'll take that
but you know what
the democrats could save themselves a
lot of trouble if they stopped being so
obviously uh terrified of the woke
they're like a tribe that is too scared
to move beyond the trees of their
village because something bad might
happen
guess what nothing bad happens if you
challenge the woke i mean you look at
joe rogan is fine fox news is fine uh uh
mansion and cinema are fine the modern
mccarthyites fold when you challenge
them and you too democrats you can win
if you grow some stones and and and go
face to face with the woke and regain
your sensible your sensible space in
this world
that's my advice to you thank you i
appreciate it yes um the producer is
telling me i have to let you have a word
oh you so here please oh okay do you
want to ask me about joy reid's dress no
actually that was amazing was it yellow
it was something i couldn't tell was it
yellow or not it was just it was yellow
wasn't it were you allowed
i asked if you had a question about that
and i was going to say no um also aoc's
backsplash i expected more
that was that pottery barn i don't know
i thought she was like kind of edgy and
and slick that was like i could have
done that
um i just want to know what happens when
cinema and aoc see each other in the
ladies room at the capitol
do they pretend like nothing's happening
your money on
well i'd take cinnamon a fight she looks
more athletic but i want to know do they
pretend like it's cool or does cinema
say i heard what you said about me yeah
i mean that's what i really care about
but all in all it's trash talk does aoc
have a strategy what is she going to go
and find a quality
primary candidate in arizona and just
keep on a bunch of dough into the war
chest and then primary cinema and then
have enough money left over to beat the
republican candidate i mean she doesn't
have that strategy she's not a tactician
nancy is the tactician she's just alive
the political power no she's a fringe
blue candidate in a deep blue district
with a lot of grass roots fundraising
appeal that's it but whatever that's it
and a bad thing
i was going to close on in a pottery
barn backdrop very well pottery barn aoc
let's go all right we got to go hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else